okay one-one know where you from
originally
where'd you grow up um well I was born
in Mexico oh really
yeah he came to the USA what age are
eleven eleven years old then tell me
about your family my family well my mom
my my mom and dad I came here to the
United States maybe about a year before
they they wanted to try it try it if it
worked out and they left us over there
and Mexico and listen I hear they
brought us over even you the whole
family was here the whole family I hope
it how was your childhood my childhood
was was good no do you still crazy not
be long again we're poor I still I mean
the airport yeah
we were poor like they would feed us
only whatever what they could afford you
know no no me no yes the simplest food
that they they could afford all right
yeah I got three sisters and the only
boy or you're the only boy yeah what
have you done for work work here well I
did go to school here I did graduate
from from high school
okay didn't go to college but I mean for
poor work I started working uh uh I'm
manufacture in place or 16 years okay
sixteen then Oh during 2005 Hurricane
Katrina I wanted to try construction so
so that was my chance to work
construction and ever since I've been
working construction or so you working
construction now excellent and are you
married I was married for 16 years I
know you divorced it was did you have
children I have one just one
how old is your another done 15 son
yeah 19 oh so you like you come down to
skid row sometimes and pick up some of
the girls that are here oh yes I'm
divorced I I tell only sometimes in you
know so I come in and pick up water how
often do you come by not very often
I used to often but no no more yeah yeah
where will you go and into your car or
you go to a hotel or would eat in the
car most other times or depending on how
it is I mean I take them home or hotel
yeah wears this costume typically Oh
at first I mean yeah you cannot get
addicted it's kind of like an addiction
I guess yeah every there's not a lot of
guys it's it's like it was it was often
before like too often and I true often
something like you can it's hard to get
rid of that craving you know yeah it's
not it's not so much that the feeling is
this just a craving like you you get a
dated fit I don't do it often now you
cut back I come back yeah you gotta I
guess you know train your brain to not
so ya know not to have you ever been
robbed or oh yeah how does that happen
oh I they always ask for money up front
so you know you give them the money next
thing you know they're they're gone with
your wallet
no not my wallet that hasn't about just
the money yeah oh I see someone no
there's no transaction there's just they
took your money and they left yeah oh
yeah have you ever been arrested for
this once winter one time yeah one they
they didn't prosecute me or anything
like that I mean it was it was it was a
dog
the cops are I not made on I just they
made huh
they were doing huh I'm stuck you do
when I'm nervous hot idea but they were
they were trying to arrest a lot of
people doing this yes yeah
hey my girl came over I was I parked and
asked me if I would if I want to have
sex and I said I didn't say anything so
next thing you know I got cops I'm back
on me like I wasn't driving or anything
so they took me in for that they didn't
they didn't know they didn't know
charges or file or anything like that
you know so but it was maybe that's why
you got back and if you ever do it that
will do it really good huh
I think it's all law-enforcement
supposed to work yeah they I didn't I
think they didn't do anything
yes yeah but II cut you got you cut back
yeah uh-huh
no more like do you think do you think
doing this kind of stops you from having
a relationship with somebody who's not a
prostitute why there's a big that less
likely hey come on it does come on I say
you know like our relationship if you
want to they want to find somebody
that's worthy of a relationship
mm-hmm it's it's hard because I mean why
would why would you go to all the
trouble of meeting somebody and like
when when this when this girl's out here
the yes Pam and that's it you know you
know how to put on wet there I had it
too you don't have to like when you're
married like you know it to me I don't
feel like I don't like I don't want to
be go through that marriage thing and
all that you know so so it's easier for
me to just I mean yeah this is a good
alternative for you long yeah do you
remember your first time doing this my
first time it was a long time ago
remarried I wasn't there is that is
after you married no I
I wonder before it was before I wasn't
there
yeah yeah what was their first time like
the first time it was it was kind of I
was actually I never had sex before so
it was my first time
oh really yeah well the first time and I
guess it wasn't a good experience hello
girl you know I wasn't so it's it's like
JA trying to learn how to drive over oh
really
it was trying to learn how to drive by
yourself you know it was you're scared
but you know you want to do it maybe you
want to learn but it's just kind of like
10 wait how old were you I was Oh
believe I was somewhere in my 19
somewhere around there I was already one
do you ever think you could fall in love
with one of these ladies
mmm it's a possum in your knee yeah yeah
then you probably have to save them get
them off drugs and all that other things
cuz it's pretty much all of them are
probably playing route drugs yeah well
they're nice girls but they're oh
they're addicted to drugs and it's yeah
that kind of it'll be a problem but
actually at some point well yeah I guess
it would take a lot a lot to get them
off the drugs yeah it hurt a lot yeah as
much as you might want it they have to
want it so yeah it would take more than
that feeling you know because that's the
feeling of what they have for that drug
is greater then you would need to
motivate them to want to do it for
themselves
yeah do you uh do you forget the same
same ladies rather than getting
different ones every time no I stick to
that same one how many different ones do
you visit here for me Danny did you go
to other neighborhoods to for this no
just here yes yeah yeah
I only know almost all there are you
typically just doing oral sex no I don't
give intercourse anything yeah always a
protection though yeah you always use a
condom there's always there's no
exception for yeah
yeah there's too many yeah there's so
many going on
yep too many deer or find you have to
use alcohol or drugs to I used to be
naca Holly me when I was married you
know when you were having trouble with
you start drinking and it makes it makes
it a habit of drinking every day yeah no
but you stopped drinking I stopped
thinking I I think maybe one Terry one
upbeat one beer mom want my month or
something like that I'm not even
finishing that's great yeah I guess when
you have so many problems you're trying
to find out what way out it was one of
them yeah what do you think of here if
you're a 15 year old son sees this video
and sees the deads oh him seeing
prostitutes how do you feel about that
mmm I don't no idea how I mean I feel
like I don't know I feel like like like
a piece of her you know I'm sure I'll
feel like a piece out words what they
say in your yeah but I mean you know II
think I mean even eventually the mom her
mom already build a lot of things in him
you know because we went to a like a
breakup and you know so she's very
totally like you don't you don't even
want to talk to me so I figured that oh
really
yeah I figured that that she already
made up so many things about me that
yeah that I don't care right now like he
don't even want to talk about to call
him and he don't answer the phone and I
take something oh really
miss elaina right now I feel like like I
don't care like whatever he knows
there's a memorial party told so many
things about me no did they don't start
around the divorced time yeah did you
ever do you ever do any kind of kinkier
things than just oh yeah the basics non
when I got divorced or is it I mean my
sex life was really boring I knew I
wanted to try new things and new you
think so
I yeah McGee kinky you know I play daddy
I think I would be brought I wrote play
I actually am I bought her a stripping
Pole and a stripping Pole in my head in
the living room I'm gonna put out a
stripping Pole now living woman now I
swing over their rooms not that that's
how kinky yeah I want to get no so
you're having you're having fun with the
girls yes and what other kind of things
you engage in ah toys I thought these
are things your wife would not really
not even do any of them and you think
you had these these desires even the
American mmm-hmm yeah I mean before I
got divorced I wanted to improve our our
situation and I guess by I might have
buying toys and all but she wouldn't she
wouldn't do it so that's one of the
reasons divorce you know but yeah I mean
when you got when you got out when your
hunger to to learn new things about
improving your sex life I guess
that's one of them you know yeah you
were craving seen you that you want to
try and and and and your partner is not
willing to try them I mean it's not
gonna work out
yeah do you ever get other people
involved other than just the two of you
I mean
I thought about threesomes treat a
threesome but I mean that's that's
something that I that I would really
really think of Marcus when you're
having a threesome with somebody that
you care about and involving somebody
else does to me that's not that's not
that's not that's not right
yet I don't know all right I don't I
have that craving to do it but I don't
wanna compromise the relationship with
with that person all right
no even even though you're just paying
her and she'll probably do anything you
like probably like I would think about
it like really hard like but I would I
do wanna try it but the moment hasn't I
think come up yet did you find your
appetite or your your desires are
getting Wilder as you oh yeah definitely
though do you get I mean definitely more
the more experience you get maybe I
believe I'm not a sex addict like I
gotta happen you know
I gotta have it yeah like the present
that girl that I'm with right now
we we spend hours and hours having sex
hours I mean we started at certain time
and we look at the time and it's like
four hours six six hours we we do it
dumb dumb that long and how much that
every time is it keeps back getting
better and better better and better
there's not one time that
not even one time that has been horrible
sacks it's been always good you know
never I never experienced that before
never and he just keeps on getting
better and better and that would make it
hard to go to a relationship with a girl
that's not a professional at this right
your likelihood of finding that could be
slim I mean right now right not up at a
point nada haha yeah I like I like I
like I like how it's going
I like how it's turning out and I
wouldn't change it for anything
no well what would you say the wildest
kinkiest thing you've done that's better
I see
for one thing I we recorded a lot of
things that we do you know record and
Polly I guess
ain't no sex ain't no it would be the
kinkiest you know okay or our abut
plugin and me me me inside I guess that
what they called EP right yeah but I
mean as far as ID is going I think we're
gonna be more creative and more
we put porn year to just to get more
ideas every time you know it's born do
you think this affects your life outside
of the bedroom
mmm-hmm they happen I mean ya know I
might even help it perhaps yeah I think
as long as you're with somebody that
that was twisted I do I guess I mean
it's good because if you find like my my
ex-wife she was boring so and I wanted
to experience new things it will it
wouldn't you know she thought I was all
she thinks I'm mom I'm a pervert you
know just by that I mean who doesn't
love sex everybody love sex
right so I guess I am a programmer and I
could be a bigger problem you know with
that right person yeah you found the
right person yeah alright well thank you
so much for talking with me thank you
for being so honest and open oh thank
you
you